foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am your
host this hour Rachel Cruz alongside me
bestselling author and Ramsay
personality Ken Coleman and we're taking
your calls America it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five talking
about relationships career your work
your money anything and everything so
give us a call so first we have Hannah
in Columbus Ohio hey Hannah welcome to
the show
Hi how are you doing great how can we
help
I have a question about my student loans
um my loans are privately owned so I've
been paying them for the last three
years but I can't make the minimum
payment right now and my question is
should I just let it continue to accrue
as I work through my debt snowball or
would that be a really bad idea
um I mean it leans on more of the really
bad idea side of the equation because
the debt snowball is paying minimum
payments on everything so you don't get
behind and then attacking the smallest
debt so
um so how much how much is your payment
every month
um so it is about 552 I'm behind 785
okay
um and what other debt do you have
so total it's about 75 000 okay and then
counting everything I have about 95 000
of debt counting everything what's the
other 20.
um 15 of it is credit cards and then the
remainder is some smaller debts like the
family and stuff family loans okay so
the 75 is your student loan
yes okay
uh and how much do you make a year
Hannah
right around forty thousand
um I do have a job interview in the next
couple weeks to hopefully increase that
okay and I'm not counting my second job
which generally makes about 800 a month
right now 800 a month okay well that's
great so how short are you is it just
you're making your payments on
everything else your four walls but just
this actual student loan payment of 552
a month how much are you short on that
um so without touching the income from
my second job I'd be short about a
hundred and fifty dollars
why would you not touch the income from
your second job
um well right now I need to rebuild my
emergency fund
um about 600 and I would like to just be
able to use that towards other debts but
okay and your emergency fund for the
thousand dollars is that right
yes okay so you'll so you have 400 in
savings you're trying to build that up
to a thousand
okay and then we're gonna start yep
attacking that okay so one of the one of
the most important things so Hannah I
would say is to get current on your
bills so with this 800 so I would what I
would want you to do is even pause the
baby steps like I like it the more you
continue to go back
uh the harder it is to go it's going to
be to go forward just on a mathematical
standpoint so
um if I were you and and is your side
hustle you doing it every night
it's about three to four nights a week
right now okay a retail job can you do
more
can you do more work more yes yes I'm
waiting for them to approve that
schedule okay that's great so Hannah I
really think in in a month uh in about
four weeks if you up you're working and
you work seven nights I mean you work
every day because it's a level of uh of
urgency because you are in an urgent
situation I mean you're not you're
getting behind which again is is we
don't want you there we want you current
yeah and you have 400 in savings so like
all of that can be fixed in about four
weeks of making some extra money uh to
be able to build up yep that emergency
fund and get current so that would be my
goal for the net for you to say hey in
the next three weeks I gotta I gotta get
this all taken care of so that's seven
hundred and eighty dollars
um
785 that you're behind
Plus what's remaining of the emergency
fund of the 600 like we want to get
twelve hundred thirteen hundred dollars
in here pretty quickly this month
and then my question is I want to walk
you through this coming on the heels of
what Rachel just gave you uh because
that's the that's great advice what is
the smallest debt and when we look at
the snowball you listed them out for us
what is the smallest debt what's the
payment on that per month
um
the smallest debt that isn't owed to
family is 735. that's a that's the total
yes of that credit card statement
correct all right and so then what's the
next one
then it would be 15 000 in the credit
card loan all right so the minimum
payment on that seven hundred dollars
that's not enough for me to roll this in
here but what I'm getting at is is is
following up with what Rachel said then
you're attacking that that credit card
because that payment there we want all
this going into that student loan
payment I'm trying to make up the
difference between work and then the
initial snowball debt that you can knock
out to where you're not falling behind
at all you're current on the student
loan until that's the last one on the
list and that's going to take you more
time but we want to quickly get urgent
to get to to get caught up to get the
emergency fund baby step one to a
thousand dollars and then I'm current
I'm making the minimum payment every
month on that student loan while we
attack the rest that's what your urgency
is about do you understand
yes okay good and Hannah for your family
for the family loans how much per month
are you paying them
um right now zero okay okay no that's
fine a hundred dollars and three
thousand dollars so okay okay exactly
the 400 but you're not you're not paying
anything currently on those
no they're they're okay with that yeah
well I was gonna ask to ask them if you
can pause any payments to them I agree
Rachel I was gonna ask you I think
that's okay but you're doing that now so
that's good so you're already pausing so
you're really getting after this first
initial credit card which is not much at
all with you pulling more hours and
getting a better job you can knock that
out fast and before you know it you can
knock that fifteen thousand dollar card
out that's a game changer what's the
minimum payment on that fifteen thousand
dollar card
um in July it'll be 295 dollars I mean
that's a race when you knock that out
now you really get this and for the new
job Hannah he says you're just
interviewing
um do you know how much will the well
the new position if you get it how much
will that pay instead of 40 000 making
in your salary job what would what will
it be
it'd be at least 55. that's great okay
so Hannah there's a lot of upside I know
you feel like it's overwhelming and when
you're behind there's a level of of fear
and like oh my gosh can this even happen
but I think you work what you can
control right now is how much you're
working and to Ken's point I would go to
your part-time job and I would say I
will work I'll close every night like
whatever I need to do go crazy for at
first like just give yourself a time
period you know three four weeks since
okay here's what I can bring in just
again get on ground level of being
current of everything being able to pay
minimum payments have your emergency
fund and then you start chipping away at
this debt Hannah hopefully you get the
new job get the raise of 55 000 and keep
this intensity going until it's all
knocked out so I'm excited for you
Hannah stay on the line and we're going
to give you Total Money Makeover because
that's going to give you a step-by-step
guide as well and motivation as you're
doing this plan so good luck to you
thanks for calling
thank you
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you guys I have I have three little ones
at home you have three big ones older
ones or bigger ones shall we say at home
and you know life it can just be really
hard it can be hard to connect with your
spouse prioritize that when there's kids
and there's life and there's work and
there's so much going on but it is so
worth it to prioritize your marriage so
that's why this fall I'm inviting you to
disconnect from the stress of day-to-day
life and reconnect with your spouse at
the money and marriage getaway right
here at our brand new Ramsey Event
Center in Nashville so for three days
October 19th through the 21st Dr John
deloney and I will guide you through the
entire weekend again away from normal
day-to-day life and with your spouse to
focus on your marriage set goals and
dream about your future so you're going
to learn how to communicate better build
intimacy set boundaries and make plan
for your money together and we've seen
it happen time and time again when you
dream together when you make goals
together create what you want your
future to look like you start acting
like a team and when you become a team
you become Unstoppable so for this
getaway again it's you guys you guys
that are killing it on baby steps one
through three keep the intensity up be
focused on your goals but if you're on
baby steps four and Beyond this is
something that could be really great for
you so tickets cost 799 dollars so again
talk to your spouse but if you're out of
debt you have room in your budget please
join us for this incredible weekend to
talk about money and marriage so go to
ramsaysolutions.com
events to get your tickets today and
there's no truth to the rumor that I'll
be watching the kids uh in a separate
room with a day camp there's a lot of
talk about that and I decided to kill
that idea oh were you gonna be
babysitter Ken yeah well there's some
talk about it I'm on a day camp you know
you know
yeah yeah no we decided against that
idea So for anybody wondering that's not
a part of the event hey maybe next year
yeah
pretty good with puppets
all right up next we have Grace in San
Diego hi Grace welcome to the show
hi guys
um my question is
how can I get my spouse more
enthusiastic about additional generosity
just to give you a little bit of
background information my husband and I
are on baby shop seven I was raised in a
Ramsey household my parents are everyday
millionaires but my husband was not
raised in a family that really exhibited
a lot of like above and beyond
generosity and so we have those budget
line items in our every dollar budget
that outline our generosity to our
church of choice and then additional
generosity but I generally find that
like I'm the one that is more feeling
led to do additional kits or give money
to people that I see or meet or things
like that so
um just looking for any advice that you
guys might have on kind of assisting my
my sweet husband with building those
muscles
uh Grace are you is he
um
hesitant when you come forward and say
hey there's this thing going on I would
love to give no no never he is always on
board yeah is he the same is he the
saver of you guys is he the saver more
of the nerd
um I would say we're actually pretty
pretty much both nerds um he does work a
lot and so it's it's like I'm generally
the one that handles most of the
um outgoing money in terms of like our
budget items and things like that yeah
um and so I don't know if it's maybe
just like doesn't have the opportunity
or not doesn't have them does it see
them as much as I do or that it's just
maybe he just hasn't developed those
um feelings or those muscles the items I
mean I would tell you Grace can correct
me if you think that this is off base
but I think I would be more concerned if
you brought if you know you're the
initiator of this and if yeah you
initiated something and he was like no
that's so I don't want no no no no
no no no no
um
you know if that was his heart then I'd
be like okay let's talk about that I
wonder what is in him that's doing that
but it's it's just the fact that he
doesn't initiate and Grace I hope
Winston doesn't kill me for saying this
I'm more of the initiator with the
giving I'll get a text from someone at
church they're like hey there's a foster
family you know X Y and Z or a tornado
came through and a team member needs
that and and again I don't know if it's
because I get it more but I'm like oh
yeah and I text once I'm like hey
there's this thing he's like absolutely
do it uh but I feel like I'm more of the
one that initiates those random acts of
giving in our relationship but I don't
Winston for that just because I I think
to your point I think it gets presented
to me maybe more frequently and Winston
is he's just more of a Savor naturally
bent more and he would tell you more
scarcity mindset like it's just it's a
natural bent but it's not that he
doesn't give or doesn't want to it's
just not
on the Forefront always like where I
feel like you can you can present like a
puppy with a broken leg or like let's
just adopt the whole family like we'll
fix it all right I get more yeah I get
more emotion from it or something you
know this isn't a popular opinion in in
2023 but I also think it's the
difference between men and women
uh you know there's a controversial hot
take that women are different than men
and and but I do think in this situation
I agree with Rachel
you kept calling him sweet precious
husband uh every time you bring it up
he's like oh yeah let's give so I I
think the question now comes back to you
what is making you call us today and ask
us for advice on how your husband can
have more of a giving muscle when what
we're hearing is he's rarely anti-giving
he just doesn't pop up the idea as much
as you do so is that does that bother
you in some way what's going on what's
behind this question
I guess
it's a tiny bit because like I said I
come from a family that's like very very
giving
um to a really like anyone and everyone
and
um
I just see that as like a big part of my
day-to-day life but and and we haven't
been married that long a couple of years
so I guess maybe it's just like not
fully integrated into you know his
recurring thoughts yet
um but I was just kind of seeing you
know if there were anything that you
guys did
um with your family or if you had any
similar experiences but
my experience is much like what Rachel
said except it's flipped Stacy is you
know she's the one that I mean it's not
flipped exact same she's the one that's
always coming to me do you feel like
that's the case with you guys 100 she
comes to you more yeah and I'm like
great but I will tell you that I'm the
one who tends to be more and it's not a
scarcity thing but I tend to be like
okay where are we at what else have we
given to this month that we can't give
to everything and everybody right right
because Stacy's amazing she would give
it all away yeah totally uh not that
she's irresponsible but that's what her
heart is versus I'm a little bit like
okay like for instance okay this is a
window in and this may help or may not
help Grace but I'm gonna be transparent
and and Rachel's get she's really good
at like putting me on the spot on the
show
my natural bent is to say who are we
giving to
what are we giving and can they handle
it
so I'm real sensitive to are we blessing
someone
like they really really need it not
enabling not being the yeah yeah so it
depends on the gift if we're talking
like like getting George like my wife
she brought I had to walk into work last
week with a pretty pink bag for George
Campbell's wife Whitney because we're
friends with them and Stacy found a
little something something in downtown
Franklin and honestly I didn't even look
inside the bag I gave it to George and
George Goes you know what it is I don't
have a clue what it is all right now
that's a dude response sure so in this
situation Grace you guys haven't been
married very long and you're bringing in
expectations to how things are supposed
to sources with Stacy and I got married
I kept expecting her to have dinner
ready at six o'clock it never happened
we're too much into marriage and I would
just be watching like the news or
something it'd be like 6 30 6 45 and I
didn't demand it I would just go hey
what do we have for dinner and she'd be
like I don't know
what are we having Ken I share the story
to say that when we get married we bring
in the culture and the expectations the
way that our house ran I would give him
uh some Grace Grace yeah because you've
got it he's a good and I would say this
too Grace I think it helps Winston and I
uh we have like one particular
organization besides our church that we
love and we both have been impacted by
so when we give that monthly it's a part
it's a part of both of our stories so
find that commonality like what's the
thing what's the
um
of stuff that he would be like oh yeah
that makes sense to plug into so I would
say that I would give him a little bit
of Grace Grace just like Ken said and I
don't think he's a bad guy and it may
never be the Forefront thing and that
doesn't mean he's a selfish evil person
at all it's just kind of how he's been
and that's okay so thanks for calling
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
caught my attention Ken yes because
America has failed Millennials so badly
that they're turning to a thousand
dollar per month side hustles to make
ends meets please so the side hustle has
become a big part of people's lives two
in five adults in the US have a side
hustle according to a recent Bankrate
survey of 2500 people and 53 percent of
them are Jen's ears and half are
millennials and then 40 percent are gen
xers and 24 are baby boomers so the
argument here which you can read some of
these data points is that millennials
have been born into a time where It's
just tough right so as you leave College
It's the Great Recession and your the
job market was all whacked out when we
all entered the the workforce and then
we were the generation that that loaded
that student loans you know to to the
degrees that we know now we were kind of
the first big generation to take those
on now the housing market it's like it's
it's impossible to buy a house now so
that's what this article is is is kind
of uh oh yeah come on Old kin here we go
this is my old man friend this is this
is I can't give his old man cranky can
take now the headlines that's true
though everything I did say is true in
defense of Millennials it is but let me
let me let me just wait a second I think
you're gonna agree with me on this one
even though you're not old and cranky
the headline says America has failed
Millennials so badly that they're
turning to a thousand dollar per month
side hustles the article goes on to say
Millennials in particular
have been struggling to keep their heads
above water for years
after hopping around a rocky post Great
Recession job market dealing with
inordinate student debt I agree with
that more on that in a moment and
shopping around a difficult housing
market all of which has made it harder
for them to become financially
independent now let's dive into this
this sounds like a sob story but here's
the reality okay America has failed
generations of students
by pushing
student loans
we have an entire documentary on it
and and borrowed future lays out the
horror stories so I will say that the
that the government the federal
government along with the student loan
programs and politicians who want to see
a lot of universities popping up all
over their state because that lends to
more taxes bigger job basis which means
they get reelected now that's all I'm
going to say about that but that's
what's going on and we have failed
people because we've put them into this
notion that getting a college degree is
the best way to success and that
narrative is changing so for that I
agree but here's the problem Millennials
and gen Z are struggling
paycheck to paycheck because they think
they're supposed to live the lifestyle
that their parents live and they don't
realize I got to build up to that and
credit cards are easier than ever to get
credit card debt at an all-time high we
hear that headline every month so you've
got young people who are absolutely
strapped with student loan debt and
credit card debt you take those two and
only those two factors yeah and here's
where we go they need an extra job and
we act like this is a crisis it's a
crisis as it relates to them having to
work a second job it's a crisis of debt
and if you remove the student loan
payment you remove the credit card
payment then these kids aren't having to
work an extra job so
this this is what's here's what's
concerning me this headline and that
excuse making by this writer is what
creates
the expectation problem that is driving
all of this I deserve this I deserve
that I want this I want that well listen
number one you don't deserve it and I
don't give a crap if you do want it if
you can't afford it then don't do it and
yet we've created this soft expectation
driven society and then we go we need to
do something about it what there's no
solution in this article at all it just
keeps talking about how many people have
to work an extra job well let me tell
you something on the Ramsey show we put
people on that stage across there that
do that extra jobs all the time and they
get debt free and none of them are
griping about it so there's the old
cranky Ken no I appreciate it okay well
and I don't have any data to back this
up so this is where you go into
dangerous territory okay but I I I am
always fascinated by generationally what
you experience right so the Boomers were
raised by people that had seen the
depression even right or or had World
War II close relatives from depression
to war to the great the great generation
right so that's what the Boomers saw
they take this whole idea of the 1950s
the man leaves and goes and works nine
to five wife stays home this whole
picture that's created you know and then
they they have kids that are now me
right so I was raised by Boomers but I
just love that word I just love it so
much it's not said as a term of
admiration
okay Boomer that's what the kids like no
I know I know you know and so like so
what we saw was something and then it
was like I think our generation was one
of the first because the internet really
started playing a part of your life like
you know later in in college when when
Facebook came about like like all this
stuff started happening this
connectivity to the world unlike any
other generation so we really became one
of the most social conscious generations
with giving uh the ability to go do
things
um that looked different than just the
standard lifestyle that was that we all
most of us saw in our parents and so it
does create this new world and then you
lay on top of all of this right you
graduate into the the housing bubble had
busted banks are closing I mean like
crazy right the Great Recession was nuts
right and you're entering that and at
the same time it's like you you have
like you said a level of expectation
that again for the first time social
media I think this level it's not just
Billboards and magazines that you're
seeing you're seeing real life people
living a certain way so subconsciously I
feel like there's some level of human
mind that just says oh yeah if they're
doing that or this or that
yeah then I should be too I'm their age
and you know what I mean like oh you're
absolutely comparison yeah all that
starts playing in uh and then you add on
student loans you know and then you can
go down the list but I think the hardest
thing and what's so difficult on this
show that we try to communicate so often
when people call in with money issues is
that like math
it doesn't have emotions
your money doesn't have feelings it is
what it is and so there's a level of
reality that has to sink in to say I
just can't do that and even though I'm
frustrated about the housing market I'm
frustrated that if I had bought a home
in 2018 it would be double the size and
if I'm buying it now like all of those
all of that is so real like that that is
a very real
um emotion and feeling to have but the
problem is is when that starts to drive
your decisions yes and there's a level
right that you have to be able to say
here's my here's my situation what what
now am I going to do about it yeah great
segue so of the response so what we gave
you were the data of of how many in each
generation are having a side hustle now
here's why
33 of the respondents said they need the
extra job the side hustle to afford
regular living expenses so these are
people that are living above their means
33 33 are going I need it just to make
ends meet or whatever my rent based on
or credit card everything else like oh
okay I want this I want this membership
here and I got this car all right so
this car payment I gotta have a car it's
800 a month so I gotta go work at Kroger
and that's not fair sorry that voice
just comes out sometimes 27 said it
helps with discretionary spending now
this would be responsible okay so now
they're going you know what we'd like to
send our kid to a summer camp or I'm
making this up and they go in order to
do some of these extracurriculars
whether they be single or married or in
a family situation 20 seven percent I
work so that we can have a vacation good
for you yeah so it's not all snowflakes
here they don't know how to handle their
money right then
um 12 are using it to repay debt these
would be Ramsey Show listeners and
viewers are going I'm getting after and
I'm going to pay off debt so I did want
to at least share that no that's good
it's not all people that are just going
I I don't know how to handle my money
but a big part of it is yeah uh We As
Americans we don't have discipline with
our money because we want it now we've
been told you get to have it now you
deserve to have it now you should have a
nice car nice house and all these things
in your 20s well and it's hard to go
backwards Ken and I think there's a
reality too once everything's paid like
just your general stuff
there's not I mean there's not a ton
left always and so uh just the price of
life and and I think inflation kind of
plays into I think there's like levels
of all this stuff that things just have
cost more and to go backwards and say
okay we're actually gonna have to cut
things to keep the same lifestyle that
we had like that sucks that's not fun
but sometimes that's the decisions that
have to be made this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show listen
if you are new to this show and you hear
us talking about extra jobs and paying
off debt and the baby steps and all this
lingo then make sure to go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button because we want you to
figure out where you are in your
financial journey be able to name it and
know what to do next to help you get
financial peace to have this level of
control over your money to have this
level of Peace because that is what is
so so key so go to ramseysolutions.com
and click the get started button today
all right going to the phones we have
Kaden in Charleston West Virginia hey
Kaden welcome to the show
thank you how are you guys we're doing
great how can we help
all right so I'm 15 years old and um I
my um I'm a janitor at my church and I
make 13 an hour nice and I have about
six thousand dollars saved up so far
nice
thank you um I have two questions my
first question is
um at what age should I begin investing
that's a great question well
um
you know one of the important things
that we talk about especially if we get
a young caller like you is that setting
yourself up well for Big Life
transitions is really important so do
you have any idea at 15 what you want to
do when you graduate from high school do
you know if you want to go into the
trades you know if you want to go to
college do you have do you have any
thoughts
um College college awesome do you know
how you'll pay for that
uh these scholarships and working okay
good for you so you'll be the one that's
going to be paying your tuition is that
correct
yes man that's awesome and let me point
this out Ken that I love Kaden that you
know that already at 15 because you know
some families they don't talk about it
until the junior is a junior in high
school and starting to think about
college and then they have this
conversation so the fact that you know
ahead of time Kaden uh is really key so
what I would be doing is instead of
investing that money we always say to
invest in you at this point in your life
and so that would be keeping that 6 000
set aside and more as you start working
in high school to be able to pay for
college so that you don't take out
student loans and Kaden that's gonna
determine where you go to school is a
big factor school choice is really
really important here so staying in
States even going to a community college
for the first year or two but making
that decision in a wise way is going to
help you not only save money but be able
to graduate and not have debt and be
able to have a degree that hopefully you
can use and that will advance against
you in your career so so I would not be
investing right now Kaden if I were you
I would keep that money in a high yield
savings accounts or even a money market
accounts and right now you're getting a
pretty great rate of return for just a
good old savings account uh and I would
put that money in there and not touch it
and let it grow and continue to fund
that account
for college and for that to be your
college tuition
yes sir that's what I would do did you
have a second question
I I do yes ma'am
so um I've also been saving up for a car
so I figured that I would save up for my
my car first and then whatever money I
have left over I'd begin saving for
college so um should I my parents had um
told me that they would match me up to
twenty five hundred dollars for a car so
um that'll give me a little bit more
money for a car and then um
yeah and so that's that's pretty much it
yes ma'am that's great I think that's
awesome kid and so then yeah if that's
the case I would take 2500 of what you
saved 2500 from them and you get a 5 000
car that'll last you through high school
and maybe even through college can would
you go cheaper Ken no I I think I think
minimum five you know I think you can
get something that's going to be uh
somewhat Dependable at five you're gonna
have to put some some repairs into that
car to keep it going on a five thousand
dollar card that's just the nature of it
just I'm looking at it all the time and
so you're gonna talk about a high miles
car uh but if you if you keep working
this uh this plan where I'm gonna put
emergency fund aside for my car and then
you're working for college tuition after
that if your parents can help someone
with the repairs you and your mom and
dad just need to be on the same page
about what who's gonna do what and all
that jazz uh you got gas money and I
remember when my son got his car last
year and he started really paying
attention to gas for the first time it
was hilarious he's like I can't believe
you know yeah I'll help you with some of
the gas like if you're going to and from
school I'll help with some of that but
you driving around with your buddies all
over the place yeah right he comes home
one night Rachel and I you know we track
our kids as any paranoid parent does in
this day and age back when you and I
were teenagers our parents had no idea
but today all the time what is this
address
you've been at the gas station too are
you hanging out in the parking lot so he
comes in and I and I noticed that I
checked in on him I was like you were
downtown Nashville oh what do you what
are you what do you what do you what do
you what do you think here I was like
what was he doing oh they were just
checking it out he'd never been down
there he's feeling free you know they
they weren't there long I could see he
was eating like they were essentially
cruising I'm guessing I love it but I
said uh you pay for that I'm not paying
for you to drive on a field trip to
Downtown Nashville that's your job you
know so get an idea of what do these
things cost this is a young man who's
really really driven he's on top of it
this is a great experience I agree with
Rachel's advice 100 Kaden but again be
really clear on what you want for the
car uh think about repairs think about
all that kind of stuff that would go
into it it may be worth getting a 7 500
car you know if you want it to last for
a while does this car last you through
college it's possible so Mom and Dad are
giving you a 2500 match
if that was me I'd be going all right
can I get 7 500. I got the 2500 from Mom
and Dad I get 10 grand I got a decent
car that should last me through college
yes well I just did a whole segment on
my show we taped it so it'll air later
on 10 cars under 10 000 and there's
great ones that's what I'm saying Honda
Civics and Camrys and you got they'll
run forever now you're gonna have to put
some money in them I would say a rule of
thumb having bought a an older Lexus for
my son you know you get a car that's uh
in that under 10 range you can look at
probably putting in 1500 to 2 000 in
their first year I think that's a fair
estimate it could be worse yeah but it
certainly could be that much but again
if you fix these cars like when the
alternator goes we bought Ty's car two
weeks later he's at prom and his
alternator goes thank God it was after
he dropped the girl off okay that would
have been done that would have been the
story I had to put a new alternator in
it you know that's 600 bucks that was
more than that actually somewhere
between 6 and hundred bucks right but
again that car will run forever if you
fix the parts and so you just gotta plan
for that totally when you're going to
pay for a car that you know for five
grand that means you're gonna put maybe
the same amount in it over the next year
to two years yep so good all right uh
let's go to the phones James in Houston
hey James welcome to the show
hey guys so thanks for taking my call
dude thanks for uh calling in we got
about two minutes James so what's your
question
I want to see what you do in my
situation I am looking at a job change
soon offered a position Here Local
Southeast Houston pays about half of
what I make now but also almost half the
hours I'm working now
um so I'm trying to get out of the field
I'm in into a new career I also have the
ability to make up that income with some
side hustles but with a growing family
two babies third on the way a little bit
of debt still to pay off just a lot of
things to balance on this decision
making wanted to see what y'all would do
how many hours you work in right now
per week between 1670 yeah and uh if you
were to take this job which pays you
half I'm guessing you're coming back
down to a 40-hour week is that right
yeah so how many more hours would you
have to work to be able to make the
budget work and not take a real step
backwards financially how many more
hours would you have to work if you take
this job
realistically 10 to 15 hours okay so
that's that's a lot better on your
schedule and does that make up the
difference financially
it should I have pretty good revenues
for side income that I'm starting to
build okay so the reason I'm walking you
through those questions is that's that's
what I would do I would go okay I don't
want to have to work 60 to 80 hours a
week that that's not sustainable I do
have to take care of the family I need
to be around I got another one on the
way and so if I can make up the
difference and I don't go backwards
financially I'd absolutely scale back
because you're really not scaling back
financially you're scaling back in that
one job but it opens up A New Path for
you so in this case I would do it it's
great awesome Ken thanks so much for a
great hour all the guys in the booth
Emily Ebu got you girl thanks for your
help and thank you America for listening
we'll be back
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with fellow Ramsay personality and
best-selling author and good friend Ken
Coleman and we're taking your calls
America so anything in regards to your
money your job your career your work
your relationships give us a call and we
will talk through your situation and
we'll give you our thoughts and
hopefully uh give you some guidance on
what to do next now if you've been
listening to the show for a while and
you're enjoying it please consider
sharing the show Word of Mouth you guys
is so so helpful when it comes to people
hearing this message and getting hope in
their life so share like subscribe leave
a review all the things again it helps
with not just the algorithm of all these
platforms but also it helps more people
get the show so they can hopefully
change their life so we're gonna go to
the phones at this hour and we got Josh
first up in Virginia Beach hey Josh
welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call and I really want to say uh God
bless you guys in your ministry that you
do you know you help a lot of people and
uh you know I listen to your show all
the time so I appreciate all of you guys
and and what you do for us thank you
thanks Josh I appreciate that how can we
help
I have kind of a complicated situation
um
I am currently doing the baby steps I'm
going through Financial Peace University
I've been doing the every dollar budget
and really been uh hitting this hard
um I'm married I've been married about
four years my wife is not on board uh
with much of the financial Improvement
um and the complicating thing with that
is
um she keeps you know threatening me
with with divorce and separation
I pay 100 of our bills and I feel almost
like a prisoner in my own home because I
help support not just uh myself but her
and uh her son I have a 12 year old
stepson and
I work full-time as an ER nurse I travel
for work and I go to school full time
and hoping to change careers so I've
kind of just been like a just kind of
like a mental breaking point I don't
know exactly where to go and how to how
to find peace at home and you know it's
uh just something hard to deal with and
that's I listen to you guys all the time
and I thought you'd be a great place to
reach out to is the threatening of
divorce
over the FPU steps or is it something
else
same page with just about anything
financially we've been separate the
entire time we've been together it's
worked for us I know Rachel you're big
on you know having a combined uh account
and the hard part about
um this situation is uh she has
financially sabotaged herself to the
point where I'm okay with the separation
um you know I want what's best for
everybody but
um she cannot support herself and her
son
okay so let me just yeah put a little
caveat when we do talk about combining
accounts uh it's yeah we think it's very
crucial and when it doesn't happen we
always say there's a reason why it's not
happening and it can be in multiple
reasons you know of they were burned
before in a divorce and they're scared
or they want the control like whatever
there are reasons of why that doesn't
happen and our push is always okay let's
get to the reasons that isn't happening
so for you just in that one example as
you said the reason is is because she
financially has sabotaged herself and I
have she's has she sabotaged herself in
other areas too Josh not just money is
this it sounds like every part of your
marriage you guys just aren't you're not
a fit what what caused you guys to get
married in the first place was it
different four years ago and it's
changed
um yes from when we first met um
everything was was great I mean we were
really getting really in love things
were great
um we actually met on vacation and it's
just kind of doing a distant dating
thing for a while and as a traveling
nurse I took an assignment out here to
kind of test how things would go it went
very good and then um she went through a
really ugly custody issue with her son
and her ex and I really tried to step up
and you know
be a good man and support her and her
son and I've been doing that and the um
the the difficult part is I didn't find
out about how bad some of the financial
stuff was until after we were married
um and there was a multitude of things
but um I've been trying to support her
and actually in getting into the
financial piece and uh trying to work
through the the Ramsey steps I was like
hey you know we're not on the same page
with a lot of things but let's let's
maybe do this together it might be like
a team building thing like hey let's get
excited about something let's do this
together and it's just opened up a can
of worms that I just did not know was
there and you know I I talk all the time
about trying to help her but now I I
can't
and it's really okay so not to get too
technical Josh I'm just like the money
side you called for the money so I know
Ken can probably speak into some of the
other parts of this but for the money
specifically what has caused her to
sabotage herself financially is it that
she spends too much is it that she's not
working is it that she yeah what what is
what's the main the main reasons
okay I'm sorry I know I'm kind of all
over the place no you're fine you're
fine no no you're great
so uh she's actually an accountant
um of all things
um so she struggles with personal
finance where you know
um I know she took out a lien against
her vehicle
um which ended up breaking down that was
about a ten thousand dollar loan against
the car which the car was you know not
salvageable so I ended up having to give
her a down payment for her to get
another vehicle uh I know I found out
that she's taken out loans against her
retirement and her credit score like I
think it's in the low 500 range so even
though we were trying to go through this
process of you know potentially
separating she can't even get approved
to get an apartment on her own so she's
still living with me because she can't
go out on her own yeah and for the last
six months even though we're basically
separated but living together I pay a
hundred percent of the bills and I just
kind of feel almost like a prisoner in
my own house and you're trying to be a
good Christian man I can't I can't
foreseeably just like hey I'm gonna
break the lease I'm gonna move out you
and your son have to figure something
out she has a lot she obviously has a
lot of Brokenness in her life and in her
story that is not dealt with and it's
coming out sideways in all these
different ways
um and so have you guys have you guys
done therapy have you guys done marriage
counseling do you have a good church
home do you guys have a pastor do you
have a local therapist that you've seen
at all have you gone that route
we've done couples therapy twice and she
actually even joined it was like two
sessions
two different no two different
therapists like 20 sessions and then she
actually met with me and one of the uh
Ramsey coaches recently and even that
didn't seem to help okay so Josh do you
want to fight for this marriage or do
you feel like you guys have decided this
Deal's done where are you at I believe
it's done I just don't know how to do it
with okay being a good person being a
good man and you know not leave them
high and dry because I just I I have a
hard time with that all right so here's
what I would recommend I I think you
need to go see some counseling on your
end and get as healthy as you can
because you're dealing with a lot and I
want you as clear as you can be with
these decisions you got to make I'd also
like you to see a pastor uh that you
where you go to church and just walk
through what do you feel is your
responsibility uh when this marriage
dissolves but if this thing is over uh
you're not responsible for her and this
kid long term if she's going to keep
making bad decisions so you're gonna
have to walk through all of this and do
what you believe is right
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am at
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Ken
Coleman and Ken you know one of the
reasons we talk to people all the time
about becoming financially free not
owing anyone anything is it not only
just gives you margin but it gives you
options gives you freedom to actually
dictate your own life versus say being
stuck in a job you hate just to pay
these bills I mean it just gives you the
ability to have choices again in life
and and that's huge and I feel like you
know you and Stacy you guys have
experienced that but that's such a
benefit of this message that um it does
that that benefit doesn't have dollars
and cents directly attached to it it's
more of a concept and an idea that is so
true that not a lot of people in
personal finance talk about when they
talk about good debt and leveraging and
making it work for you all this they
don't talk about the effects of just
when you don't owe anyone anything you
have autonomy and you have options yeah
you know it's it's true Stacy and I I
and I want people to hear this that are
that are sitting there in the middle of
this so they're getting ready to start
this they've just joined the show and
they're going okay the baby steps I get
it I want to get rid of debt in my life
I want to have Financial Peace but I
want you to think of it Beyond just the
financial piece when Dave has said for
decades live and give like someone like
no one else uh the idea here is is that
you really are free when you ask people
that step on that stage all the time
across the studio from us uh you know
what does it feel like And the emotions
are it just feels so free and and what
happens is now they they they can decide
to do things that they never could
before and so
um I'll take people back if you don't
know our story I was in my early 30s
when I decided to make a wholesale
career change I was heading One
Direction 30 what 30 32 31 32 when I
decided that I thought it was time to
Pivot but I I struggled for two years
just to get the confidence uh to step
out and do it it wasn't from a money
standpoint it was actually do I have the
talent to pull this off yeah it's a risk
can I provide for my family if I move
into broadcasting well when we finally
decided that it was time to to take a
shot uh we were uh let's see I was 34 34
35 we had three kids
um
and we had a nice home nice neighborhood
and we decided we were going to go all
in on my radio show which was in the
Atlanta area the Ken Coleman show and I
said okay I can speak I had already
gotten my first book deal uh but we're
gonna go all in on this radio show get
sponsors for it and one of the things
that we decided to do and again this is
because we could we had walked through
the baby steps we had taught FPU so we
knew how to squeeze and so we decided we
were going to pull back uh on our
expenses and we were we knew we were
going to make less money for a season
this was a calculated risk Rachel yes
not a crazy risk just all right we're
gonna give this a run for one to two
years we know how to budget we know how
to cut one of the things we did was we
decided to sell our house because we
were going to make a nice windfall from
it but we were going to save that and
then we were going to rent and cut our
expenses drastically smaller house
so we did that and about a year into
that move uh God opened up the door to
actually come here to Ramsey and that
was not a part of the we didn't see that
we just were like we're gonna step out
and do this and when we did it uh God
stepped in and and for somebody out
there that's going okay all this God
stuff I don't go to I get it so let's
remove this the the the the the
spiritual blessing part that we see but
what was actually practical for us is
that because we didn't have that
because we knew how to manage our money
and budget and we knew how to cut cut
cut cut when we paid off all of our debt
we realized that we could take a
calculated risk and not go backwards
financially
long term short term yes not long term
and so we look back on that fondly Stacy
and I as
we wouldn't have had so much faith if we
didn't have the financial freedom to say
we can pull this off so we I tell the
story to say whatever your situation is
folks on the other end of this debt-free
journey these baby steps
so just college funds paid for it's not
just a nice retirement it's not just a
paid for a house it's really margin and
when you have margin financially watch
this you have freedom to make different
choices and try some things and live
that life that you really want to live
whatever that is whether we're talking
about a professional context or we're
talking about some personal decisions
you want to make it doesn't matter
margin leads to freedom and that freedom
leads to that life that you truly want
to live and that's what everybody's
looking for it's just I want to live my
life yeah forget the freedom politics
side of it just free will like sure I
just want to do this here when how why
so I share that story to encourage folks
that maybe thinking about this journey
and going this is a slog
or they're in the middle of it that on
the other side of this whether it's a
professional dream or a personal dream
or a financial dream
that's what this is all about it's not
just about discipline and budgeting
that's what we do to get margin right
but this is about Freedom oh yeah and to
be able to have choices in your life and
the ability to make the choice right I'm
like because for so many people they're
so strapped in it and I think when you
kept saying you know live the life that
you want to live I think part of the lie
in our world today that we've believed
is the kind of life I want to live looks
yeah nice cars it means we go on
vacation whenever we want you know all
this and what ends up happening to that
lie especially if you don't have the
money for it you end up in debt for that
right and then it gets you right back to
the cycle so the life you really want to
live you guys is what we're saying is a
life of peace a life where you sleep at
nights a life where you actually have a
say over your own money like there is
something so powerful about autonomy and
to say it I have the ability to make
choices in my life and the hard thing is
is money you're not right wronger and
different we all have to have it we all
have to manage it whether you manage it
well or you manage it terribly it's a
part of your life it's a tool and so you
have to be able to say okay I can't
escape this it's going to be a part so
either it's going to be a thing that
controls me and the thing that forces my
decisions or it's a thing that I'm going
to control and I'm going to actually
tell it what to do so
um there's there's such power in that
you know there's a reason why everybody
loves
fairy tale stories and Disney and
cartoons there's a reason why we all
love to take our kids there
because all of us wanted all of us want
to dream all of us do dream we want our
dreams to come true it's not a silly
child's fantasy yep what are you
dreaming about right now totally
whatever it is whatever your answer is
when you heard me say that what are you
dreaming about right now what do you
long for
on the other side of that
is the discipline
to work the baby steps to get to a place
of financial margin your dream is that
close many times if it's realistic and
it's actually fundable uh then then take
hold of this that's why we do what we do
that financial piece leads to uh you
taking a shot you got one life take a
shot what are you dreaming about and you
can make that dream come true but but
you won't without margin and without
margin it's a nightmare because it will
haunt you I never got a chance to take a
shot at that but I did have a nice F-150
yeah I that's the true trade-off I don't
need to be so I don't want any Downer
guy but it's like you can have all the
nice stuff now but never have that
fulfilling life whatever that dream
looks like doesn't have to be glitter
quality of family quality relationships
quality of right these things around you
that when people are on their Deathbed
what do they talk about in surveys show
this concept and there's always studies
about this about like what do they say
top five top five one of the top five
answers is I didn't live the life true
to myself
living through someone else living
someone else's dream uh comparison
trying to keep up with everybody else's
life and I let that dictate my decisions
instead of Justice I didn't live the
life that I desired to live and you
can't when you have no margin yep
absolutely yeah it's powerful and I will
say this too Ken because Winston and I
were just even texting my husband and I
this morning about a project that we
want to do and at the house and I'm like
and it doesn't stop we're on baby step
seven but we still have to save towards
this thing the discipline continues it's
not like you get to baby step right you
know four five six seven and suddenly
it's like Millions just fall out of the
sky no you're still having to implement
this stuff but you do it with such
control you do it on your terms and no
one else is and that's the freedom of
margin Ken is talking about which is so
so powerful I love that word Ken such
encouragement this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
now
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees and
there one
guarantee and
and free see whyblinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wise go
to blinds.com for more information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show so
listen you guys we all have we have
people that tune in every day to this
show and they listen to every episode of
the Ramsay show and they know this stuff
but they still feel stuck and why is
that well because knowing about money
isn't the problem actually doing it is
where you see progress personal finances
eighty percent Behavior it's only 20
head knowledge and The Proven way to
change your behavior with money is by
taking a University Financial Peace
University class this class is the
difference in trying just to get into
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer you will have a
coordinator holding you accountable and
other people in the class pushing you
and cheering you on that's why this
class has worked for Millions after nine
weeks you will never handle money the
same way again you will make progress
faster than ever so don't just listen to
the show commit to doing what it takes
to win so join an FPU class Financial
Peace University at ramseysolutions.com
FPU again that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
all right we're gonna go to Brian in
Atlanta Georgia hey Brian welcome to the
show
hey guys how are y'all doing we're doing
great how about you
I'm doing well thanks for having me yes
absolutely how can we help
yeah so I'll get right to the point I'm
currently in an internship and my
company offers a 401k
and I think I already know the answer
this but I'm fairly new to the show so I
probably would ask should I invest in my
company's 401k or just start my own
personal Roth IRA and invest through
that since my internship is temporary
yeah it's a great question do you have
um any debt Brian
debt free oh good for you so you're in
college right now
yes ma'am good for you and how much how
much do you have left in the internship
and how much you have left to school
serve a year and a half left of school
and probably
I guess about a month and a half less
until I go back to school okay that's
awesome
uh and and you're playing on you're
planning on just paying for school you
have it paid for tuition and everything
for the next year and a half
yes I am awesome good for you Brian so I
would hold off on investing in the
company's 401K I think it's awesome that
they give you guys the option uh to do
that even as interns but I wouldn't it's
a month and a half long and by the time
honestly you get all the paperwork and
everything through it's like you're
gonna have to move it over to a
traditional IRA after that and it just
kind of becomes or yeah it just becomes
a lot so because it's so short term I
would say no and I would also say no
right now too Brian it's just because
you're in school and there's a lot of
transition that will happen is going to
happen that will happen that you're not
aware of there's just a lot of Life
between now and the next two years so
once you graduate from school you know
transitioning into the real world it's
it's expensive so just having cash on
hand is going to be really important so
I would just take any money that you
would have invested in any money that
you make above that tuition and I would
be saving just in a high yield savings
account or a money market accounts for
these expenses that are gonna be coming
up and then once you graduate and you
land a full-time job you're going to be
already you're gonna be ready to invest
and we we encourage you to do 15 of your
income into retirement and that's going
to be split between yes that 401k at
your company or the company you will
work for in the future if they have one
a matching situation and then the Roth
IRA so you're in the exact right
headspace Brian
um looking at your options I just think
it's a little too soon just because you
have so much transition coming up in
your life and and yes compound interest
is a wonderful thing and we talk about
it a lot on this show but you're gonna
have plenty of time like if you graduate
and you start a job and you start
investing even by 24 25 years old
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
so there's not a rush here and I would
rather you have cash on hand to be a
buffer between you and life during the
season than it being invested yeah I
agree I wouldn't add anything stack the
cash I think you're absolutely right
it'll come your time's coming now you're
going to get some people that may
disagree with that advice yeah but we're
looking at the big picture and and make
sure that you stay focused on the big
picture
okay sounds good awesome thanks Brian
and well done on all the work and
internship in college you're doing
you're doing great all right let's go to
Gabe in Kansas City Missouri hey Gabe
welcome to the show
hey how are you we're doing great how
can we help
um so I'm currently in three thousand
five hundred dollars in debt and that's
in family debt and I don't make a
consistent income
to afford both to pay my grandpa back
and uh make my bills
okay
um how old are you Gabe
I'm 20 man 20. are you in school are you
working full-time
I'm working full-time okay what do you
do how much you make
um on a good month I can make up to
three thousand dollars on a bad month
I've made as little as 200 what do you
do
I am a line cook and
um I help my friend manage his stream
okay so what's causing the big
discrepancy if you're a line cook and
are you able to determine ahead of time
or in the middle of to go this is not
going to be a good month it might be a
medium month
give us a little more detail um
it's it's just it just varies
um something like uh in July like July
4th we're gonna be incred I know I'm
gonna be working seven days a week
making a lot of money but a month like
um January I worked maybe four days out
of the month
okay what you doing the rest of the days
yeah
um I actually go take care of my parents
okay what's their situation
um it's uh
my dad's just uh using the Navy so he's
he's not home very often my mom just
it's it's a lot of uh personal stuff I I
don't like to oh talk about it too much
gotcha well let me ask you this then
without diving too much into that uh are
you able to work let's take that January
example I understand that you're going
and doing something with Mom there but
are you able to work
I am very able to work well then you've
got to have a backup plan if you're
gonna stay in the line cook side of
things or any business that you would
call seasonal I'll use that as a
description a lot of people do seasonal
work and so in the seasonal times when
it's hot I mean you're working a lot
you're making some good money but then
when you've got these down much you've
got to have a backup plan and so we can
walk you through and Rachel can help you
with the budgeting side of things and
paying off debt but you've got to have
consistent income that will help you uh
walk through this so when you've got
these off weeks you need another job
that has some flexibility or you're
going to have to walk away from this
this line cook job and go well it's
really good when it's good but I need
something that's more consistent
wait is that Dave Ramsey
uh Ken Coleman
close enough
close enough close enough
I was going to say oh I have this um
baby steps to a millionaire book and
I've read the entire thing and I tried
and unfortunately I used all my savings
and everything to pay for my bills and
I've looked to um talking about uh
consistent uh having a consistent cash
flow that's what I helped my friend do a
stream uh I get some money from that but
yeah but my friends is trying to get his
pop but listen Gabe I'm glad you read
the book I go back and reread it uh
because you aren't getting enough
consistent income and when you get
consistent income then the baby steps
it works okay but you don't have
consistent income I'm thrilled that July
4th week you're going to make a bunch of
money but you've blown through your
savings because you don't have
consistent income so I don't care where
you do it how you do it I don't care if
it's Dave Ramsey or Ken Coleman if we
don't have consistent income we cannot
get out of debt we will not be able to
save an emergency fund and we will
always be behind the eight ball the
metaphorical eight ball or we're just
trying to play catch-up you're a young
man seems like you're you're you're able
to work you need to be working so let's
make some better choices let's get a
solid foundation of financial stability
based on a job or jobs that bring in
enough income to fix your situation
that's right thanks Ken thanks again for
the call we'll be back
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
so this is fun news Ken apparently
MasterCard launches a global plan to
recycle credit cards really what do you
mean recycle you mean literally recycle
they're trying to save the environment
yes so on Wednesday they launched a
global project to recycle credit credit
and debit cards as a part of a plan to
save billions of cars in circulation
across the industry from landfill
oh so they're partnering with a British
lender
HSBC Holdings and MasterCard said Banks
across the world and some of which have
launched local initiatives that would be
able to join the program and help them
build a build economies of scale what is
what okay so this is my favorite part
under this plan MasterCard will provide
shredding machines has anybody who's
been listening and watching the show for
any amount of time see the beautiful
irony of this MasterCard is going to
provide credit card shredding machines
so that they can recycle around 3.1
billion dollar or billion cards that are
in circular each one of these machines
Rachel is capable of holding 10 000
credit cards so we should have one
delivered here and put it right out well
you know what we should put it right
next to the debt free stage and people
can bring their credit cards in and
shred them I think that's fun and what
they want they want to recycle them into
more cards but no no not here we will
not we could just we'll recycle to
recycle but we're not going to recycle
to cruise I was gonna say we would burn
them but then that would make the
environmental a smack because that would
hurt the ozone if we burned recyclable
credit cards because I'm that's terrible
idea Ken did I just say that on the air
come on I I am sorry but you know you
can't cause an ozone problem but anyway
the irony is Rich MasterCard wants you
to turn in your old cards and instead of
throwing them away and they go to the
landfill they want you to shred them uh
you know they could have coined that the
Ramsay way I really do think we should
get a machine we gotta know something I
think that's great we should call
MasterCard up Austin and say listen
um we want one of those machines uh we
talked about it on the air
and we don't like that you give people
credit cards but we love that you're
trying to save the environment and we
want to help we love that you're cutting
them up send us a machine but you know
what we could do we live in Tennessee
with a lot of a lot of rednecks that can
work on machines and I think we get a
shredder and then we have some of our
friends here that are mechanically
inclined they come in here and they turn
it into uh a chipper like a wood chipper
so when we put the cards in it makes
that loud noise and it just spits out
the credit cards into little itty bitty
pieces
and just like a wood chipper do you know
have you ever seen that before like a
wood Tripper no can you act like I'm 95.
do you not know what a wood chipper is I
mean I think I do it's a big giant
machine they take a whole tree
and it turns into like mulch it's it's
the greatest thing you've ever seen in
your life it's so pleasing to watch I
think we should do that with the credit
card all right I think it's a great idea
MasterCard on uh shredding cards we are
all for that they're not going to stop
issuing cards though just shredding
these shredding them yep all right let's
go to the phones and we got Hannah in
Illinois hey Hannah welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call you're so welcome how can we help
so I was wondering little backstory I am
currently in the middle of baby step two
with about uh ninety thousand dollars of
debt to go and I work
full-time plus go to school full-time
plus I have two side hustles that I'm
doing part-time wow when do you sleep
I don't
tell me about these side hustles really
quick what are they I'm just curious
and then I
so I worked there part-time about 10 to
15 hours a week okay and then I go into
different stores and I do ads
um like into like Kroger and put up
their ads for them oh okay what do you
mean put up their ads what does that
mean like the banners
oriented thing and you go in and put
them in how many hours a week are you
doing that yeah
um so that ranges from anywhere from
like two hours to five or six
okay so we'll call it four to six hours
so three to six hours a week
or is that a month
that's a week okay gotcha all right keep
going so lots of stress um I have
definitely felt my anxiety go up so
because of that I had really taken a
dive into uh my crochet and my crafting
project
um in the spirit little spare time that
I have
um and so I was wondering I was thinking
about starting another side hustle of
selling those because it's not a cheap
Hobby
um and to try and help bring some of
that money back all right so this is the
idea that I'm spending money to do this
while I'm in baby step two but at the
same time I feel like my sanity needs
this what will it what will it sell for
well it's a tough sell for
um so I mean I've seen things from
anywhere from like small projects and
like towels and stuff go for like three
or five bucks I've also seen like
stuffed animals go for uh 30. how much
do you think you could net Hannah
realistically and maybe let's just say
you took the ads job away and you got
three to six hours back in your in your
week and you focused on this have you
done any calculations on what your net
profit will be
um not a whole lot yet it is nice
because I do get a nice discount
um with Joanne so I get a lot of my
spending I do a lot of my shopping there
um for this
um but I haven't done like an actual
okay so what are you making per hour on
the Joanne's job and the ads job
uh 13 an hour there at which one
Joanne's
uh yes and then how much you make it per
hour for putting up the ads
uh 13 an hour there oh 13. what do you
make just at your full-time job
um at my full time I am
I've seen just over 20.
20 000 a year
uh twenty dollars an hour between an
hour I'm so sorry okay
um okay
so is your quest so okay you should not
start another side hustle you you need
to be efficient right now and I love
that you're working so let me first
applaud you for working but Rachel I I
think that the hobby
um I don't like that it's an expensive
hobby uh but I understand having a
little bit of a mental break and having
something to kind of recharge with but I
don't think this is this is a wise
decision you don't have a lot of time
and you need to be making the most of
your time and I'd like to see you get
one side hustle so if you want to stay
at Joann's that's fine but if it were me
I'd be going I need one side hustle not
two
and one that pays me 20 an hour or close
to twenty an hour because I'm making 20
an hour in my regular job so I know I
can do it and I just think even if you
make it the most I'm like I can yep and
and less time so look you need some time
yes take care of yourself more money
less time
and just work the baby stuff and I know
Hannah it's probably it's part of you
being at Joanne's because you love
crafting obviously it's a passion for
you so I understand that but I would say
until that this debt is paid off your
number one goal is to make as much money
as possible to get out of debt so that
you can then not even have to work at
Joann's you can just pay for the crafts
because you have margin in your budget
you don't have debt so I think that's
the ultimate goal but
um yep I would say definitely working
working less you want to take care of
yourself you know when we talk about
gazelle intensity Cannon and getting out
of debt you know for some people they
can they can handle a level of a
workload for a period of time and they
just go at it right and then but we also
in that in that same breath we don't
want you spiraling out mentally either
right so I'm like there's very much a a
balance here review Hannah taking care
of yourself and then what Ken is saying
being wise with your time choice and
your job opportunity choice of where
you're working so more money less time
yeah Roi fly return on investment right
that's a it's a financial term but
um you have got to get return on impact
here and so what that means is all that
time that you're putting into work it's
got to be a nice return and so the side
hustle on a passion project that's down
the road I love that idea shelve it
shelve it for when you're debt free and
you want to start selling your favorite
hand towels or whatever it is you want
to do you know sweaters for Pet Rocks
all of it works but it's not something
we're going to make money on right now
we need to go make money get that 90
grand paid off Hannah you can do it you
got this girl well thank you Ken for
being a wonderful co-host
this hour thank you to everyone in the
booth to make this show run and thank
you America for listening this is the
Ramsay show and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of at Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsey
personality Rachel Cruz hosting this
hour with best-selling author Ramsey
personality and fellow friend Ken call
me yes good to be with you glad you're
here and thank you America for tuning in
and it is a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're taking your
calls on everything from career work
money relationships give us a call so
we're gonna start off the phones this
hour with Kayla in Houston Texas hey
Kayla welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call I'm
excited to get this question answered oh
I'm so glad we are here for you Kayla
how can we help
yes so
um my question is if I should move out
of my parents house and if I should if I
if the answer is yes what do I need to
have prepared to do that
um so I'm turning 27 next week
um I just got a job in January and I'm
thinking about 60 60k
um
good for you what are you doing oh I'm
gonna count it good for you yes you
should move out
I should move out okay unless unless
there's some extenuating circumstances
to why you're wrestling with this
meaning do they need you in the home is
there something special here or is this
just you've had a season where you've
been with them and you're wondering if
it's time to get out it's nice not to
pay rent yeah the saving money whole
thing right what's the story yes the
story is there's there's no rush to my
parents they I mean we have a great
relation great relationship and so it's
really just there's nothing wrong with
home life
um I I started the plan uh took
Financial Peace like in February and so
since then I've paid off about like 4
000 good for you hard as that is because
I'm at home and so I guess it's really
just fear on my end sure of course by
the way that's normal
you know you've had a good life you got
a great relationship with your parents
very safe and so now it's about adulting
I think the kids call it these days and
so that there comes a lot of fear there
so let me tell you what I when I when I
coach people in in the area of their
life
um that they're afraid of doing
something fear to me is I'm worried that
something bad is going to happen that's
how I Define it right you call it
anxiety if you want to but fear is I see
something in the future or I don't see
something clearly and I'm afraid if I
move forward in uncertainty Rachel that
something bad will happen and so I think
that you have to get in your own mind
what are you specifically scared of I
love that you were brave enough to share
that so let's just play it out what are
you afraid of if you move out on your
own what's that fear get as specific as
you can with it
the fear is just
I don't like paying for things
that's gonna come true because I hate
paying for stuff Rachel I know I don't
think you have anything I don't think
that's your fear what are you really
afraid of
[Music]
um
probably just leaving it's a single
parent house so probably just leaving uh
my dad by himself
okay
and just because of just loneliness and
he won't have a companion there that
kind of thing or is there like a health
issue at all
the companion part yeah yeah that's
totally fair yep I totally get that yeah
and you know Kayla I think it is
um especially in your circumstance when
it is a single parent household and you
know whatever had happens
um you know with your mom whether
divorce or he's a widower you know
there's a natural caretaking when she's
kind of become an adult and you start to
stand on your own that you start to ha
you put on some of those roles of like
okay I want to make sure I take care of
my parents so even that emotion Kayla is
very very normal and I'm going to
applaud that I think that's a really
kind part of who you are and you
probably have a great relationship with
your dad but I would say one of the best
things that you can do for Kayla
is to move out and and honestly not
because again that it's a bad situation
you're in because obviously it's not but
something happens Kayla to you
when you move out on your own and I
always use this as an example it's kind
of a silly one but it's just the truth
like
something happens in your brain and in
your daily habits when you go to the
refrigerator and open it up like oh crap
I'm out of eggs I forgot to buy eggs
okay I gotta go to the store I have to
like you start to have to problem solve
from small life issues like eggs or
something something in the groceries
all the way up to big things and you
just start to have a level of of
self-sustaining and a level of dignity
that is created in that for you to I
think help advance in careers and
relationships it just it causes you to
grow up and Kayla I think you're at a
place that you can do that and I would
encourage you too that you don't have to
move far right if you get an apartment
somewhere and rent for a little bit it
can be close to your dad and you guys
can have like hey let's do weekly nights
where we Taco Tuesday where we hang out
yeah I mean you can still have a
relationship with him it won't be as
convenient obviously because you're just
not right there but I think Kayla for
you as someone and you know their late
20s I think this is a really good move
for you and it's going to cause you to
grow up in many different ways and it's
and long term
I think it's I think it's best for you
and Kayla I'm going to suggest that
there's another fear and it's really
hard to articulate a lot of people don't
know how to articulate when they can't
articulate a fear I think the fear is
the unknown you just don't know what
it's like to live without your dad right
well I kind of do because I lived out of
state for a little okay but then you did
that didn't go so well so I came back
what happened what happened what caused
it not to go well
I was in Los Angeles it was very
expensive so I came back but here's the
deal Kayla and I'm going to bring this
back to money I think the fear of the
unknown is absolutely normal in fact
it's what we all encounter when we try
something new whether it's a class you
know at your local gym or you're anytime
we step into something new the unknown
it just gets us that's just who we are
as humans so financially you've already
paid off four thousand dollars you got
this new job it's a good job so work of
work with a budget the more you make
this move start running numbers yeah
everything from groceries to and I think
since you have the safety of living with
your dad right now I would use this and
say before I move out I'm gonna actually
come up with a budget a plan and I'm
going to start paying for things that
may be dad's paying for and let's let's
go ahead and practice this let's do a
drive run yeah Rachel I don't know what
you think about that but I think that
will help her deal with the unknown of
hey can I do this and do life well
living on my own I think that's an
important step Kayla if we give you
every dollar the premium version that
connects to your bank it's our it's our
budgeting app and it allows you to
really budget and see where your
paycheck's going and start to plan out
will you use it
yes if we give it to you okay we'll hold
on the line and Emily's gonna pick up
and I think Ken that's a great I think
do a mock budget and just see okay
here's the rent that I can afford uh
here's what I need to be looking for it
just starts to narrow this whole idea of
I'm moving out and it starts to give you
some guard rails and I think it's I
think it's really once you see the
numbers you won't be scared because you
go wait a second I can actually do this
and then that moves to I'm going to do
this yeah that's great thanks Kayla for
the call we'll be back
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
hmm
welcome back to the Ramsay show uh
King Kong I think we'll get to the calls
uh this hour but I'm so nervous about
where she's going folks I I am Buck hold
on let me put my seatbelt on click we're
staying the course oh good I wish we
could we're going to the question
conversation that was that was in
commercial break on air but we will not
do it for you a little behind the scenes
we have some of the most exciting
conversations during commercial breaks
you wouldn't even believe it that's what
they should put on the YouTube I'm gonna
give a teaser because on Monday
afternoon George Campbell and I for
smart money happy hour recorded an
episode about conspiracy theories and
money
and it was the joy of my life no one
loves a conspiracy theory it will be
released later this month so let's just
say good question did we land on the
Moon
no
it's gonna light YouTube did you see the
technology
it's the Soviet Union we were really
trying to beat the Netflix special at
your
urging and I will give you a little I'm
going to give you a little nugget here
after watching that I think it's highly
plausible that they created the whole
lunar Landing in a studio somewhere I
think it's pausing that's all I'm gonna
say I said plausible and because of you
how does good does that make you feel
because I'm anti-conspiracy no I know
you are you're so boring now my brother
who's the most logical guy on the planet
he believes this he went to Houston and
saw everything and he said after seeing
it there's no way that they took a
speech that they like did all this and
they broadcasted it live yeah I know
we're gonna get kicked off the air we
really are it's been great great I've
enjoyed serving you on the Ramsay show
if you were an astronaut that landed on
the moon
um they're not listening right I'm not
sure for you or for you or for you in
life I don't think we please forgive us
forgive her she knows not what she does
it's just it's time for question of the
day it's just fun so the Ramsay question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly is the place to find Reliable
help for your home from trusted locally
owned businesses like Glass Doctor Mr
Handyman and Mr Appliance visit
neighborly.com today to find a home
expert available to serve you today's
question comes from Hannah in Virginia
she writes in I currently work two jobs
one full-time job making 1600 a month
and one part-time job making 800 a month
at my main job I'm running into
Financial issues with my boss recently
I've got the raise that I've been asking
for and then with no warning I get it
taken away as a lesson
ouch
it turns out my boss had been doing
Shady things financially with other
employees for example
he makes some of my co-workers work
overtime but refuses to pay them or he's
not giving them all their hours on their
paychecks and not paying them in full
well this guy this guy even still
working yikes with my other job I'm
waiting to hear if I will get full time
I'm wondering if I should quit my
full-time job before knowing if I get
full-time hours at my second job I can't
keep working this toxic environment with
my Shady boss uh okay so uh
I don't know what kind of financial
situation you're in
but no matter how toxic this is and I
believe you Hannah but I don't think
this is toxic enough to for you to walk
away without another job to go to now if
you have the financial margin where you
you can look for two or three weeks uh
then then I'm okay walking away today
but unless it is an abusive dangerous
situation
I would you know bite the stick go in
deal with this clown
let's turn our uh Focus to getting
another full-time job
and then if the part-time job turns into
a full-time job walk into that so my
point is hang on and don't trust
anything he says don't trust anything
make sure he pays you he just feels like
a crook though no I will tell you what I
would do this is a very good point I
would document to the best of your
ability if he's if he's not paying you
what you've been yeah uh what you've
worked uh now he can dock your pay like
he did as a lesson
why would a what's the theory behind
that well it's manipulative well sure
but like what what like why I don't know
I don't know if he's having a hard time
meeting payroll I don't know if she's
working for a small business and this is
the lesson B just that like I have
control I did something wrong and so
it's like uh being grounded it sounds
like Financial grounding by your boss
which is really weird so weird so we
want to get out but let's do what's best
financially and uh and I think you're
gonna be fine yep but yeah I would not
put up with this nonsense no no all
right let's go to the phones we have
Mariah in Houston Texas hey Mariah
welcome to the show
oh Mariah are you there
yes I'm here oh wonderful thanks for
joining us how can we help
yeah thanks for taking my call
um I just have a lot of different things
but um
currently I'm in a financial crisis so
to speak I'm going through a divorce I'm
a newly single mom oh I'm sorry
um yeah I moved back home to where I
lived before getting married and
everything
um we sold before I moved we sold my
Volkswagen cars for three grand I used
some of that to move and the car just
wasn't reliable to have my son in he's
only one but um I kept the car that we
had in both of our names but now
it's out for getting taken and
um I can't afford the monthly payments
anyways
um I don't have another car I did buy a
cash car last month but after driving it
a few times the engine blew out and it's
not it's it can't be fixed I don't know
what else to do
um I'm in baby steps two
um but I just don't know I I don't know
what else to do other than try to find
some other cash card but I don't want to
have that risk again
of it not being reliable you know what I
mean so well the engine going out that
first month the the engine going out the
first month did you was it the only type
of car that you could afford were there
other options did you know that it was
in bad shape did you you know have a
mechanic look at it before you bought it
or anything
my my dad had looked at it and
everything and he
um it was a rebuilt engine and it only
had 79 000 miles on it it was a 2008
um car Rav4 Toyota it was I loved it
um he looked at it and just within the
week of me having it
um I was driving back from Dallas to
Houston and it just the engine blown on
me gosh yeah okay all right so you there
was an internal oil leak inside of it
and no one could tell no one knew okay
it did yeah okay so Mariah
um are you working right now
yes thankfully I was blessed to keep my
job through this
I make about I make about 38 a year
um but in income is different like last
month I brought home 2 300 this month I
brought home 27.
um it just depends what do you do Mariah
I work with people who have Medicare
insurance so I get inbound calls and
then I ask them a few questions and then
I get them to the licensed agents and
that's pretty much it I have my son home
with me
um full-time
um except he goes to his dad's once a
month for a week at a time so I have
that time but as far as I've tried to
look for extra income working maybe like
I get off at five so I can work 5 30 to
12 o'clock at night like while he sleeps
and everything I just I don't know what
to do yeah
I'm so sorry yep I know I've tried doing
every dollar but I cannot get my brain
around it and I want to Financial Peace
University I just don't have the money
and I just I don't know what to do okay
that's why I was like I'm gonna call and
see what they say yes how recent was the
divorce
we're still going through it okay so um
we go back the next one to finalize
temporary order where are you living
I live in Houston right now well like
like uh just you and your son like in an
apartment did you get a house parents an
apartment yes ma'am okay all right um
you know what let's do this hold on the
phone okay we're gonna hold you over the
next segment cause I think we can walk
through a couple of options for you uh
and we will definitely gift you
Financial Peace University for sure
that's on us so and I want to get her
with one of our financial coaches yeah a
few sessions just to get her a baseline
absolutely so Emily um will you well
hold on the line Mariah because we will
pick you up next segments
um after this break and talk through
more options for you but that stuff is
coming towards you to to you to help you
because I know you're in a really tough
tough situation so thanks for calling
hold on the line we'll be back
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show you know
paying off debt is smart investing and
saving money is smart but there's one
key to winning with money that people
Overlook all the time and that is
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that's where insurance
comes into play now there are about 10
kinds of insurance coverage that you
might need based on what your life looks
like today so we built a tool called the
coverage checkup to show you which types
you need to add drop or adjust well even
rank coverage your rank your coverage
list by importance email it to you and
then connect you with Ramsay trusted
insurance provider so that you can get
your plan in place fast seriously this
could be the most important five minutes
that you spend today Donald H wrote in
and I like the way you put it he said
for anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it now you never know when
something will happen and you never want
to leave your family in a bad situation
so visit Ramsay Solutions com slash
checkup that's ramseysolutions.com
checkup and don't let an emergency sneak
up on you protect you and your family
today
all right let's go to Mariah back to
Mariah in Houston Texas and Mariah was
on in the segment right before this and
she is going currently through a divorce
Ken she's been trying to budget she
can't get a grip on it and it just seems
overwhelming her car died out you know I
guess a few weeks ago she was saying and
she really doesn't know where to begin
or how to move forward is that accurate
Mariah
yeah and I still have the car that we
both have in our names but it's about to
get taken because I can't
it costs too much I can't afford it so I
just I don't know whether to use my
savings to
make a payment to get it off of the repo
list so okay so let's work next month
all right so we're gonna jump in we're
gonna ask a lot of questions right now
to just get a handle on the numbers and
see if we can give you a a clear path
forward okay so when you talk about the
car that you guys jointly own and you're
about ready it's about ready to get
taken is that by the repo so you've got
all that coming your way and they've
said we're coming to get it
yes okay how much is owed in order to
not get it repoed
okay and two thousand eight hundred
dollars is owed on uncle
yes for right now for it to be on no
that's just back payments okay okay yeah
so what is the car worth
um when I do when I looked it up it was
about eighteen thousand okay and you owe
how much on it not can not even
including the 2800 and back payments
What's the total debt on that car
thirty six thousand seven hundred ninety
five okay all right and so what is
keeping you from selling that car and
getting at least eighteen thousand for
it
I'm I'm scared I don't I don't know
um okay so if your dad you got a good
relationship with your dad you got some
friends you got some people in your life
if you called them up and said hey I
need help I'm just so overwhelmed right
now help me sell this car and you put it
on Facebook Marketplace or whatever but
if you can sell that car and you can and
let's just say you get 18 for it okay
that is that is dramatically slashed
some of your debt and we're beginning to
crawl out here and you can get some
momentum not to mention it's it's it's
you're gonna get something for it do you
understand what I'm saying and so you
can pay the 2800 back payments you know
you at least get some of that uh taken
care of and then you go get a loan from
the credit union for the difference and
so you've got a lot less money that
you're having to then pay back and that
will go now into your debt snowball do
you understand what I'm saying so far
yes you can do this Mariah how much do
you have in savings
um it's about
um 1400 1400 okay and what other debt do
you have
I have two credit cards and then a
lawyer
um so all together it's about ten
thousand four hundred forty okay
um
2600 of it is from credit card and then
the lawyer is 7 800. okay
um well I would do what Ken says I would
sell that car today so that you don't
get repo because that's going to ding
your credit you're not going to have an
asset I mean it's just it that's you
know the worst case scenario for sure so
if I were you I would sell it uh where
did you get the 18 000 I'm just curious
um I looked it up on Kelley Blue Book
perfect
so I what kind of car is it it's a 2017
Ford Expedition it's got about a hundred
and one thousand miles on it we just got
it back December 2021 so okay okay so
yes if I were you I would sell it for
that 18 pay the back payments and then
take 400 from your emergency funds
um and and put towards this car too I
mean I would go ahead and just like
lower it as much as possible
and and then you'll take you'll get a
loan out and uh for the difference like
Ken said and then I would start just
working my way down that I would I would
do your you know you said your credit
cards 2600 I mean I would go down the
list
which is the debt snowball smallest to
largest and then that car loan or that
Malone you'll take out for the
difference will be in that debt snowball
and with 38 000 array I'm just curious
you know there's so much
um work from home opportunities Ken a
lot of people are remote right now do
you think with your skill set Mariah
that you could look around and see if
even getting a 50 000 a year paying job
I just wonder how much you can bump that
38 000 in just your your normal working
hours by just applying and getting some
type of job that's paying more do you
think that you have the skill set to be
able to make more
um yes um I just don't know what's real
and what's not
um the the job I have now is pays really
well for working from home so I just
I'm just I'm scared to quit this job as
well now being newly single well you
wouldn't quit it until you had another
one secure though but I'm just wondering
if you went and looked and you know go
online and just see what other
opportunities because a lot of people
are remote work I mean a lot of people
are working from home and still making
uh great money Mariah you could also
just look for a part-time job a gig kind
of a job that works from home as well
you and and so if you're at home because
we got to save up some money to get you
a car that'll move you from point A to B
too because you got a car that the
engine's blowing up so on top of all of
this
um you you need to be if you can if you
can work a second job from home and
increase that income to maybe 58 60 000
whatever all this extra money right now
here's the good news Mariah despite all
of this stuff that's happened to you
this debt burden that you have is
actually very doable you can knock this
out but income is going to be the game
name income and discipline does that
make sense
yes sir and listen we're going to get
you with one of our financial coaches so
don't feel like Rachel and I just hit
you with all this stuff because I I can
feel on you that you're overwhelmed and
I get that uh bless your heart you are
going through it right now well let me
tell you something
you're a mama bear and there's no
stopping a mama bear and so right now
you're feeling overwhelmed and uncertain
that every dollar budget's got you I
don't know it's feeling complicated
something's going on there and so we're
going to invest in you with a financial
coach one of our coaches that's going to
get you in a solid situation where you
go I see what I've got to do but if you
will commit to this and you will do this
I'm telling you you're going to be debt
free before you know it and Mariah do
you have family in the area that maybe
even could watch your son two nights a
week
um well if you had to leave and go work
somewhere for four hours
no not right now
um I want I I'm planning on I moved it
was such a it just it was such a
um
fast decision that I had to
um knew that I just I I found something
I could afford my brother lives down the
street but he works so much okay yeah um
totally totally but everything else said
I've already tried
um getting a loan I just don't know
which places to go my credit's so low
because of the Expedition and we had our
house as well which that's a whole
another day would kick my butt on that
but um
um it's both of us that's on it so I I
don't know our coach our coaches can
help you you're not alone in this okay
you're not alone you can do it we'll
help and Maria I'm so sorry and again I
think the fog and the stress of all this
change and this heartbreak and going
through a divorce is so draining it's so
exhausting so just know good days are
coming that's going to start to clear
you're going to start to have a handle
on what's going on you're gonna start to
have control again over your life and
you're going to be able to see that hope
because it's out there right we can see
it for you and so hold on the line
Emily's going to pick up to help you
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day comes from
Hebrews 11 3 by faith we understand that
the worlds
plural can worlds were prepared by the
word of God
so that what is seen was not made out of
things which are visible
knowledge is the currency of the
universe Giorgio
it's sucralose uh from ancient aliens on
the History Channel
oh man see that's that picture for our
viewing audience they put up there
that's that's that was for you Ken yeah
that was for you that guy she that
people use that as evidence that maybe
people have been abducted by aliens that
guy I that's where people draw these
conclusions you may have seen stuff by
the way we have a poll going right now
at Rachel Cruz on Instagram and uh I
think we should report this to the
viewing and listening audience
okay 30
37 on my side which is yes the aliens
are real sure
and then the uh 63 for Ken 63 of
Rachel's fathers are sane uh and the
other 37 are not or whatever followers
don't always represents
me he yeah well there you go I'm just
kidding I'm gonna do a poll on mine too
later so go to action later oh your
audience I'd be like no of course my
audience is stable educated like I fully
expect that mature we'll see you know
wouldn't it be funny if mine flips that
would be actually make my day
all right do it Ken put it out put it on
to your people because I want to know
check it out later later this afternoon
this evening at Ken Coleman I'll put up
a poll you can you can vote both sides
multiple votes feels like a Friday I
don't know how you're feeling that's how
I'm feeling I just think that America
wants to talk about these things every
once in a while we talk about life and
money all the time and you know it's
every once in a while it's fun how about
life not here on Earth
exactly it should be a whole segment we
kind of made it a half a second as I
recall I know okay it's threatening to
take over another one if we don't get to
the phone we're gonna go to Isaac in
Oklahoma City Isaac prepare yourself
because I'm gonna ask you something real
quick Isaac do you think that there's a
chance that there's some other living
being in the universe besides just us
uh I think I'm kind of on Ken's side
man man this is gonna be a good time all
right I guess we'll take your time so
glad to help a stable human being how
can I help yeah
my question is more along the line of
career development all right so is there
a time that could be considered moving
too fast with Career Development with
any company I know that you shouldn't
hold back on an opportunity due to the
fear of failing because you can learn a
lot with that but I'm wondering if there
is a instance that could be considered
as moving too fast I certainly think so
I think that we can take things that are
offered to us that we aren't ready for
and that can be a negative meaning you
know we say in life all the time you're
never ready to be a parent you're never
you know and all that's true but I do
think there are times where we are our
eyes are bigger than our belly if you
will and we'll say yes to something
because we don't want to turn it down uh
or someone will promote us too quickly
and we just simply weren't ready for it
from an experienced standpoint and skill
standpoint and that can catch you up but
be more specific because I feel like
you've got a real life situation
yeah yeah so the company that I'm with
right now I've been with them for five
years so to get a little background uh I
worked through a Technology Center uh
got a technical degrees my associates in
applied science and worked my way up as
a instrumentation technician from there
got on with my company I've been with
them for five years
um I worked three years as a technician
and then was able to roll over to a new
opportunity as a project INE coordinator
did that for one year and got the
opportunity again uh to put in for
another position to move as a
instrumentation engineer without a
actual engineering degree to be able to
start working in that field and uh been
doing that for about six months now and
an opportunity has presented itself
within that same career path as the uh
leader within that company on the
reliability side so been kind of
struggling on if that's something that I
should put in for I know that leadership
is an area that I find fulfillment in
and I enjoy doing but I also enjoy the
technical side as well okay so the
struggle is they're not pushing you into
it and offering it to you it's just open
and you're wondering should I throw my
hat in the ring yes sir yeah I think it
comes down to what's the long-term play
for you you know leadership will always
be available to someone who keeps
getting promoted that's just the nature
of how we view work in America you know
you do well and they offer you a
promotion and eventually you're getting
promoted into a leadership role but if
you really like the technical aspect of
this right now I'm not sure that um that
I would throw my hat in the ring for
this right now
um if you really enjoy this and you're
getting great experience that is setting
you up for something you want to do long
term so on the current ladder that
you're on this newer job within this
company is that more the line of work
that you want to do long term
uh I think long term I would want to get
into a leadership role and have some
direct reports that I can impact on
where they're going with their Career
Development as well
um but this is definitely something that
interests me I'm not sure if it's
something that I'd want to do for the
next 20 years right but no I get it but
you like this line of work to where if
you do it now you could lead people
doing it in the future yes
yes that's what I'm getting at I think
you there's a wrong answer here but I I
think if you want to get some more skill
and more experience in this particular
let's just call it uh trade or craft
that you're in right now
it'll help you when you lead people that
do that later on does that make sense so
it comes down to who do I want to lead
where do I want to lead and if I stay in
this current role does that set me up
for that or do I throw my hat in the
ring for this new opportunity which one
of these sets me up best for where I
want to be long-term leading so who am I
leading where am I leading and I would
go with the the answer that is the best
decision right now that sets you up for
the future knowing that neither one of
these decisions are is a bad decision
correct
right yep that makes sense where's your
gut before you call this you had a gut
feeling yeah so I think like you were
saying either way it doesn't hurt
putting in uh putting my name in the Hat
for it um that at least gets with my
current leadership that I have within
that company and lets them know that
eventually that's where I'm wanting to
go for a five-year plan something like
that even if it doesn't work out okay at
least they know the path that I'm
wanting to go on it's kind of where I
was at with that right well then then I
think that's a good move throw your hat
in the ring there's no guarantee you're
going to get it and the fallback is
you're in a good spot anyway so go for
it how old are you Isaac
good for you good for you and you've
been with this career how long
uh industry for nine years and has been
with this company for five years awesome
so great well congratulations because
obviously you got options you're doing
great stuff yeah and you have options in
that so
um yep trust that gut Isaac because
that seems right throw your house I
agree throw your name in the hat in the
ring
[Laughter]
throw your throw your name in the Hat
and then throw the hat in the ring I see
what you did there there's there's two
steps you know the problem is my old man
phrases confuse you and you did your
best it's not your fault it's my fault
what is it it's throw your name throw
your hat in the ring yeah like that's
what I was saying yep but I've heard the
whole pick a name out of it I think you
were I don't know where you were going I
don't know you know but it worked it
works well and I think can I think
Isaac's a great example of there is
something about the Excellence in what
you do and when you're working for a
company or at least in an industry when
they recognize that you know his
question was gosh is this too big of a
chain or you know is this too much am I
growing too fast there's also a part
when you prove yourself and you do what
you're supposed to do that's I mean
that's kind of here at Ramsay the
attitude of like if you if you do you're
key results areas your kras is what we
call them and you do them well
naturally you're going to get more
responsibility and continue to move up
so that's a very good point you know
that's like catching a wave and if you
catch a wave sometimes in your
professional life and you will you can
really Advance quickly so again it comes
back to do I think I have what it takes
meaning I may not have the skills yet
but I got the raw talent and they'll
train me to get the skill and if I love
the work and enjoy the work and I'm
willing to put in the time the effort
I'm okay failing I'm going to learn as I
fail and grow then the answer is always
yes yep absolutely it's a no-brainer you
know so there you go well and obviously
if you get offered something don't fake
it till you make it I hate that advice I
do too I'm so glad you said it that gets
you that gets you burned that gets you
in big trouble too so make sure that
yeah it's it's credible it's a pretty
good point it's okay to say not yet yes
it may feel like a no but it's really a
not yet that's right that's right so
great well Ken thanks for a great hour
everyone in the booth for making the
show happen thank you guys and thank you
America for listening we're glad you
tuned in and this is the Ramsey Show
we'll be back
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]